près de dix jours après le putsch qui a
renversé le président et brême boubacar
kéïta les militaires refusent toujours
de regagner leurs casernes
le renversement du pouvoir par le groupe
d'officiers a mis fin au mouvement de
contestation qui agite le pays depuis
les élections législatives contestées de
mars avril mai les colonels désormais
aux commandes sont surveillés de près
par les pays voisins
les dirigeants de la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest la cedeao qui soutenait le
président face à l'opposition ont imposé
des sanctions économiques au mali deux
jours seulement après le coup d'état
il demande aux militaires insurgés
d'engager une transition civile au plus
vite
il demande aux responsables du cnsp
d'engager une transition civile
immédiatement en consultation avec la
kul conventionnelles les partis
politiques et les organisations de la
société civile et tous les autres
acteurs qui peuvent publier à la mise en
place de solutions de sortie de crise
aucune structure militaire devrait être
au-dessus du ps donnent la transition
les figures de la contestation dans le
pays qui ont rassemblé des milliers de
manifestants dans les rues se montrent
quant à eux prudents à l'égard des
militaires après s'être félicité de leur
initiative et demande à jouer un rôle
dans la transition politique
je me le dis c'est elle ne s'intéresse
que perçoit personne je dis bien
personne
[Musique]
les militaires ont promis de mettre en
place des élections dans un délai qu'il
promette raisonnable en attendant les
pays voisins disent tu officiellement
craindre que le vide institutionnel au
mali ne favorise les ambitions des
djihadistes dans la région mais certains
dont le pouvoir est contestée
redouterait également une contagion
révolutionnaire
[Musique]